[موسيقى]
اسره لا
كيدي لذيذ ومفيد حين تاكلني ستطلب المزيد
وعشقني لذيذ ومفيد حين تاكلني ستطلب
المزيد وعشقني عب عنب انا العنب عنب عنب
انا انا العنب عنب عنب انا العنب عنب عنب
انا انا العنب كثيره الواني شكلي بهي
ومنعش عصيري حلو شهي كثيره الواني شكلي
بهي ومنعش عصير حلو شهي هلم يا شطار غنوا
معي عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب لذيذ
ومفيد حين تاكلني ستطلب المزيد وستعشق ني
لذيذ ومفيد حين تاكلني ستطلب المزيد
وستعشق ني قبل الاكل اغسلني وكلني نقي انا
بالفيتامين جد غني قبل الاكل صلني وكلني
نقي انا بالفيتامين جد غني كي اعطيك
الطاقه وجسما قوي عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب
انا العنب عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب انا
انا العنب لشعبيته عند الجميع يعشقون
الطعم الحلو البديع ل شعبيتي عند الجميع
يعشقون الطعم الحلو البديع بين الفواكه
نوعي رفيع عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب
عنب لذيذ ومفيد حين تاكلني ستطلب المزيد
وستعشق ني لذيذ ومفيد حين تاكلني ستطلب
المزيد وستعشق ني عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب
انا انا العنب عنب عنب انا العنب
عنب انا انا
[موسيقى]
العنب